bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
mitraillent l'opo dauliach c'est un
proche conseiller du président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky ça a été son
négociateur en chef avec les russes il
est avec nous depuis kiev qui est fou ce
jeudi les premiers ministres allemand
italien les présidents roumains et
français sont venus un jour vraiment
historique a déclaré volodymyr zelensky
monsieur peau de yack une question
simple mais importante derrière sow
symbole et at il des actions qui vont
intervenir qui font que c'est un jour
vraiment historique pour l'ukraine
c'est très important parce que j'ai
l'impression
les trois cas la france l'allemagne et
l'italie ont pu parler d'une seule voix
ils ont montré que l'europe est
effectivement une nulle et que l'europe
comprend
tels sont les motifs de cette guerre et
comment cette gardois ça commence et se
termine et d'après ce que dit monsieur
zelensky et nous espérons que le crâne
recevra le soutien est là d'un
nécessaire sur les bases de parité alors
on sait que certaines déclarations du
président français manuel macron n'ont
pas plu président hélène ce qui est le
plus généralement aux ukrainiens
notamment quand il a déclaré ne pas
vouloir humilier vladimir poutine est ce
que les choses ont été clarifiées entre
votre président et le président français
à propos de cette volonté d' emmanuel
macron de ne pas humilier entre
guillemets vladimir poutine
bien d'autres choses
je voudrais à diviser cette question a
de quoi nous comprenons que chaque pays
a sa politique rieur et par à partir de
ce qui est nécessaire à l'intérieur donc
c'est que le peuple français
souhaite bien évidemment la position de
maquereau est définie par les attentes
du peuple français c'est la première
chose est la deuxième chose en euros
qu'on avait une autre vision de la
fédération de russie qu'est ce qu'on
voit maintenant on pensait que la russie
se conformer aux règles morales de
conduite mais en fait seul après ce qui
s'est passé à y retourne par exemple
nous avons vu que poutine viole tous les
principes humains et les principes et
les règles de conduite d'une guerre je
pense que ce voyage a montré
comment se comporte la fédération de
russie et qu'il faudrait la traiter
différemment que les autres pays au le
pays civilisé et une troisième chose
nous pensons que
monsieur élèves ce qui est toujours
efficace dans l es rencontres
internationales est de même pour
monsieur mac ronde et donc leur
rencontre
personnelle a été très importante pour
comprendre pourquoi le chrono mènent une
telle politique disons assez dur et je
pense que monsieur zelensky a réussi à
être effectivement un très efficace dans
ses discussions avec macro avec draghi
itunes alors très efficace est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il a obtenue une sorte
d'engagement des manuels mâcon de ne pas
toujours appelé vladimir poutine ou
vouloir le rencontrer sans véritables
concessions de la part du président
russe à l'avenir
non
je pense que nous devons mettre les
accents de façon correcte eyliac 2e les
partis qui sont en guerre c'est la
fédération de la russie qui a agressé le
cren donc l ukraine ça c'est d'un côté
et de l'autre côté
les rencontre avec poutine a pour
expliquer que la guerre quand elle est
menée par poutine après
dangereuse pour le monde entier
ce
sérère peut être intéressante mais je
pense que mener un dialogue avec la
fédération de russie et avec poutine
personnellement est important il dans
l'absolu mais je pense que le président
céline ce qui a mis les accents de façon
incorrecte comment est-ce qu'on doit
comprendre l'attitude de la russie du
point de vue politique et du point de
vue mais les terres pourquoi est-ce que
c'est dangereux pour l'europe à moyen et
à long terme nous pensons que c'est un
dialogue qui est très important pour
messieurs macron pour monsieur chose
pour monsieur draghi qui ont pu voir de
leurs propres yeux
les destructions de cette guerre dans la
région de clientes et c'est très
important de pouvoir discuter avec le
président de l'unss qui après cela et
maintenant ils comprennent beaucoup
mieux les causes et les conséquences de
cette guerre et nous pensons qu'elles
auront une vision plus globale sur
comment et pourquoi il faut fermer cette
guerre et non pas sur les conditions de
la fédération de russie avec les
concessions territoriales
car si on les accepte la guerre va
continuer et poutine vaudra de plus en
plus c'est toute l'europe pourrait être
en fait attiré dans ce conflit on sait
que pour vous les livraisons d'armes
occidentales sont fondamentales est-ce
que elle s'accélère est-ce que vous
pensez que vous pouvez encore inverser
la tendance notamment dans le donbass
voire peut-être en crimée parce que je
crois comprendre que c'est toujours un
objectif stratégique pour votre pays
ce matin
j'avais comme enfermé par la deuxième
partie
effectivement elle est parée tout le
territoire de l'ukraine est
arrivé à l'intégrité territoriale
de 91 est une tâche prioritaire pourquoi
parce que si les russes devaient rester
sur des lots territoire est prégnant il
continuerait à attaquer ce serait une
guerre longue qui durerait un an deux
ans ou plus et vu
qu'il continue à
rester en fait sur leurs positions il
est très important de renforcer le pack
et des sanctions contre donc leur
scénario ne nous convient pas parce que
si la russie ne part pas suffisamment du
point de vue mais les terres et ils vont
continuer l'escaladent anti ukrainien à
l'intérieur de leur pays dont on peut
attendre une guerre encore plus large
que ce qu'on voit maintenant donc nous
pensons que les européens qui ont visité
qu'ils le prennent hier à
féron les
compressions à biot est nécessaire et
comprendront que les quantités d'armes
les vrais ainsi que la vitesse de leurs
livraisons devront être augmentés
car notre armée est vraiment efficace et
ils sont capables de mener à une guerre
efficace
nous allons le faire la seule question
et j'espère que
vous le comprenez car le président de
links qui a expliqué à ses partenaires
c'est là de façon très claire donc nous
avons besoin d'une parité en ce qui
concerne les forces mais les pères et
les équipements militaires pour
renverser la tendance pour faire sortir
l'art mais
heureuse de notre territoire nous
soulignons encore une fois nous avons
aucune intention de nous en prendre aux
territoires de notre pays mais nous
avons droit nous avons besoin d'avoir à
en territoires libérés et libre si on ne
termine pas la guerre en sortant
complètement la fédération de russie de
notre territoire le club ne pourra pas
se développer économiquement de façon
adéquate non personne qui sont partis à
l'étranger ne pourront pas retourner en
ukraine
nous ne voulons pas qu'une armée de
réfugiés ou craignent eux restent sur le
territoire de l'union européen nouveau
nous voulons qu'ils reviennent très
rapidement grelots peu de dire que si on
n'a plus beaucoup de temps est ce que
vous pouvez confirmer que ce vendredi un
remorqueur russe en mer noire a été
frappé par des missiles ukrainien est ce
que si ça signifie une volonté
ukrainienne de passer à l'offensive en
mer noire
[Musique]
je peux dire seulement que toutes les
opérations mais les terres qui sont
venus chez nous sont menées par les
forces armées
donc il n'ya que
le quartier général des forces
arméniennes qui peut commenter
ce qui se passe bien évidemment on
essaye toujours de passer à l'offensive
y compris
sur les territoires du sud y compris
dans la mer noire mais en ce qui
concerne l'affirmation de telle ou telle
frappe c'est le quartier général qui qui
va le faire et justes en conclusion en
2000 vous pensez que la guerre va durer
combien de temps les locaux de l'iac
vous vous savez en deux mots c'est
impossible de loisirs mais je nous avons
le consensus en ukraine concernant ces
questions
[Musique]
la guerre
en fait si on reçoit les armements
lourds assez rapidement la guerre ne va
pas durer au-delà de 3 6 mois et danse
avec la toutes les conditions réunies
nous pourrons reprendre notre territoire
et par ailleurs si cela se passe la
russie ne pourra plus menacer l'europe
et semer le chaos donc pour bien
terminer cette guerre il nous faut
vraiment des livraisons d'armements
lourds de la part de nos partenaires et
bien évidemment il faut une défaite
militaire des russes à l'est et au sud
du pays mélopées d'eyliac conseiller du
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky
merci beaucoup d'avoir consacré un petit
peu de votre temps pour cette interview
sur france 24 et merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi sur nos antennes
[Musique]